>> TO GET MORE INFORMATION.
>> THEY MIGHT BE AFRAID TO
>> Tucker: GOOD TO SEE YOU.
IT'S BEEN ALMOST FOUR MONTHS
SINCE PRESIDENT TRUMP
ANNOUNCED HIS INTENTION TO END
DACA, BARACK OBAMA'S PROGRAM
AS MINORS.
SINCE THAT TIME, LAWMAKERS
HAVE BEEN TRYING TO HAMMER OUT
A PLAN THAT WOULD PROTECT DACA
BENEFICIARIES FROM BEING
REASONABLE.
BUT AMNESTY SHOULD ONLY BE
GIVEN IN RETURN FOR REAL AND
LONG-TERM IMMIGRATION REFORMS.
OR IT WILL AMOUNT TO ANOTHER
BETRAYAL.
THE KIND THAT GOT TRUMP ELECT
IN THE THE FIRST PLACE.
AMERICA REDESERVES REAL
BORDERS AND THE POLICIES THAT
COUPLED WITH THE EMPTY
PROMISES OF FUTURE BORDER
ENFORCEMENT AT SOME POINT.
THAT IS WHAT WE HAVE HAD AT
SOME POINT.
BEHIND THE STRICTER
IMMIGRATION LAWS SHOULD NOT BE
A HEAVY LIFT FOR THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
FOR ONE THING AMERICANS WANT
WE KNOW THAT BECAUSE A NEW
POLL BY NUMBERS USA ASKED
LIKELY VOTERS HOW THEY FELT
ABOUT THE VARIOUS ASPECT OVER
THE IMMIGRATION POLICY.
THE ANSWER SOUNDED A LOT LIKE
A TRUMP CAMPAIGN SPEECH.
CONSIDER CHAIN MIGRATION.
57% OF THE LIKELY VOTERS SAID
IF DACA BENEFICIARIES GET
AMNESTY THEY SHOULDN'T BE
ALLOWED TO BRING FAMILY
MEMBERS HERE.
31% OF THE VOTERS DISAGREED
WITH THAT.
HOW ABOUT THE DIVERSITY
LOTTERY?
YEAR TO ENTER THE UNITED
STATES.
GIVES THEM VISAS.
THEY ARE SELECTED AT RANDOM
WITHOUT REGARD TO ANY
QUALIFICATIONS, ENGLISH, OR
JOB SKILL OR ANY OTHER FIT.
50% SAID IT SHOULD BE
ABOLISHED ENTIRELY.
EMPLOYERS CHECK THE LEGAL
STATUS OF PEOPLE THEY WILL
HIRE.
57% OF THE LIKELY VOTERS SAY
THE CONGRESS SHOULD REQUIRE
EVERIFY FOR ALL HIRE SOMETHING
THEY CAN'T CLAIM IGNORANCE
WHEN THEY HIRE ILLEGALS.
VOTERS ARE NOT JUST OPPOSED TO
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
A STRONG MAJORITY WANTS TO CUT
ALL IMMIGRATION, INCLUDING
LEGAL ACROSS THE BOARD.
THIS COUNTRY ADMITS A MILLION
LEGAL IMMIGRANTS A YEAR.
60% OF THOSE ASKED WOULD LIKE
TO CUT THE NUMBER IN HALF.
IF NOT MORE.
POLITICAL TERMS THE NUMBERS
ARE HUGE.
REPUBLICAN WOULD KILL FOR
SUPPORT ON ALL KIND OF OTHER
MORE POPULAR THAN DEFUNDING
PLANNED PARENTHOOD OR CUTTING
TAXERS FOR THE WEALTHY OR
MORE POPULAR THAN ALL OF THAT.
IT'S ALSO THE MAIN THING THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP RAN ON LAST
YEAR AND THE CENTRAL REASON HE
WON IN THE UPSET VICTORY.
THIS SHOULD NOT BE HARD.
A MONTH AGO THE REPUBLICANS
UNITED TO PASS UNPOPULAR TAX
REFORM BILL.
THEY SHOULD COME TOGETHER TO
PASS A FAR MORE POPULAR FORM
OF IMMIGRATION REFORM.
BUT THE OPPOSITE IS HAPPENING.
A NUMBER OF SENATORS REPAIRED
TO CAVE COMPLETELY ON THIS
QUESTION AGREEING TO AMNESTY
WITH NO SERIOUS CONCESSION IN
RATHER THAN ENDING IT AND
REALLOCATE THE LOTTERY VISAS
TO A DIFFERENT CLASS OF
UNSKILLED IMMIGRANTS.
NOT ONLY WOULD A DEAL LIKE
THAT HURT THE COUNTRY, VOTERS
SAID CLEARLY AGAIN AND AGAIN
THEY DON'T WANT IT.
THIS IS A DEMOCRACY AFTER ALL.
OR AT LEAST IT WAS.
LAWMAKER.
IF YOU SEE THAT DEAL COME OUT
OVER, IT'S TOAST.
A SHORT EPITATH, TOO.
SUICIDE.
CONGRESSMAN DUFFY A REPUBLICAN
REPRESENTING WISCONSIN.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
>> GOOD TO BE WITH YOU.
HAPPY NEW YEAR.
>> Tucker: HAPPY NEW YEAR.
THE POLL NUMBERS ARE STRIKING
TO ME BECAUSE THEY SHOW THAT
THE PUBLIC IS TOUGHER ON
IMMIGRATION, LEWDING LEGAL
IMMIGRATION EVEN THAN THE
CURRENT PRESIDENT WAS DURING
THE CAMPAIGN.
I'M WONDERING IF THE NEWS
FILTERED DOWN TO REPUBLICANS
IN THE CONGRESS WHO SEEM MORE
LIBERAL ON IMMIGRATION THAN
THE VOTERS.
>> LISTEN I DON'T KNOW THAT
THE CONGRESS IS THAT LIBERAL.
IF THE REPUBLICANS ARE NOT
WOULDN'T MIND A DACA AMNESTY
FIX WITHOUT BORDER SECURITY
FIX BUT A FAST MAJORITY OF
REPUBLICANS STAND WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
WE WANT TO FIX THE SITUATION
AND FAIR BUT WE WANT TO SECURE
A BORDER AND BUILD A WALL AND
FIX CHAIN MIGRATION AND FIX
LOTTERY SEASON.
IF THE DEMOCRATS DON'T START
TO NEGOTIATE FAIRLY ON THE
ISSUE, THERE WILL BE NO DEAL
FOR THE DACA KIDS.
I GET YOUR CONCERN.
I HAVE TO TELL YOU WHAT.
I SIT INSIDE REPUBLICAN
CONFERENCES ATLANTA IS A GREAT
UNITY AROUND THEE, OF FIXING
TWO CAUSED -- AROUND FIXING
THE PROBLEM AND WHO CAUSED THE
PROBLEM.
THEY PACK THEIR BAGS AND COME
IN ON THEIR OWN AND WE BELIEVE
AMERICANS CAN PICK AND CHOOSE
WHO COMES IN THEIR COUNTRY.
AMERICA OR -- M.I.T. OR WHAT
VARD OR LOVE AMERICA AND WANT
TO WORK OR THE DARELY FARMS.
WE NEED PEOPLE WHO LOVE TO
WORK AND LOVE THE COUNTRY AND
WE GET TO PICK AND CHOOSE.
YOU DON'T JUST PACK A BAG AND
COME ACROSS THE BORDER.
>> Tucker: PARDON MY
DIFFERENT FROM THE 17 OTHER
CAMPAIGNS REPUBLICANS ARE
RUNNING IN ONE RESPECT.
HE IS TOUGH ON IMMIGRATION.
HE SAYS HE WANTS TO BUILD A
WALL.
WE ARE A YEAR IN.
REPUBLICANS UNIFIED TO PASS AN
UNPOPULAR TAX BILL.
THEY TRIED TO GET HEALTHCARE
THROUGH.
THEY DID ALL MANNER OF THINGS.
THEY HAVEN'T GOTTEN TOGETHER
WHY IS THAT?
>> I HATE TO GET IN THE WEEDS
WITH YOU BUT YOU KNOW WE COULD
PASS A FUNDING BILL FOR THE
WALL IN THE HOUSE.
BUT WE CAN'T PASS THAT IN THE
SENATE, THOUGH THE REPUBLICANS
CONTROL THE SENATE THEY HAVE A
FILIBUSTER RULE.
YOU NEED 60 VOTES SO NINE
DEMOCRATS HAVE TO VOTE FOR THE
FUNDING.
THAT BECOMES CHALLENGING FOR
US.
I WOULD LOVE IF THE
BUT THAT IS NOT THE REALITY OF
POLITICS IN THE SENATE.
SO WE HAVE TO LEVERAGE DACA IN
EXCHANGE FOR BORDER SECURITY
IN OTHER IMMIGRATION REFORM.
THAT IS THE WAY THE SENATE
WORKS.
I DON'T LIKE IT BUT THAT IS
THE TRUTH.
>> Tucker: TO GET TO ONE OF
CHAIN MIGRATION.
MOST PEOPLE LOOK AT THIS AND
SAY, YOU CAME IN THE COUNTRY
ILLEGALLY.
UNACCOMPANIED MINOR.
BRING ALL YOUR RELATIVES WITH
YOU.
WHAT NUMBER OF REPUBLICAN
DISAGREE WITH THE STATEMENT IN
THE HOUSE?
>> VAST MAJORITY AGREE IF YOU
ARE A DACA CHILD YOU SHOULDN'T
BE ABLE TO BRING IN YOUR
PARENTS THROUGH THE CHAIN
MIGRATION.
BUT TAKE A STEP BACK.
DEMOCRATS WANT THE CHILDREN TO
BE CITIZENS IN FIVE YEARS.
THEN THROUGH CHAIN MIGRATION
BRING THEIR PARENTS IN LEGALLY
WHO BROUGHT THE CHILD IN
UNLAWFULLY.
THIS IS INSANE.
THE REPUBLICANS WON'T STAND
FOR THAT.
THE REPUBLICANS MIGHT NOT HAVE
RUN ON IMMIGRATION REFORM BUT
THE POLL NUMBERS YOU CITED AND
THE SUCCESS OF TRUMP MADE IT
CLEAR WE CAN HAVE A STRONGER
BACKBONE AND FIGHT FOR
IMMIGRATION REFORM THAT WORKS
FOR THE COUNTRY.
THAT IS ONE OF THE BENEFITS OF
TRUMP AND HIM DRIVING A
MESSAGE OF THE EQUITY AND
FAIRNESS IN IMMIGRATION
REFORM.
I THINK THIS, THE REPUBLICANS
ARE GOING TO HOLD THE LINE.
IF THEY DON'T, I THINK WE
HE IS NOT GOING TO SIGN IT.
>> Tucker: I DON'T KNOW
ABOUT THAT.
I DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER.
I KNOW AND I'M CONVINCED WE
GOT TRUMP IN THE FIRST PLACE
BECAUSE CONGRESS IGNORED WHAT